tu sais bien que tu vas devenir madame
marthe aux afro et qu on a parlé à
montrer c'est le clown qui sort avec ma
soeur ce mec est un nul
j'ai besoin de points d'accord pour
demander angie larmes alors montre moi
que tu es digne d'elle dis moi ce que tu
dis on vend patrouille rien que tous les
deux une nouvelle mise à l'épreuve
tous les nouveaux dealers de la ville
semble connecter à antonio pop de miami
trouve moi ce que tu peux sur ce cas le
jure grand max mais si c'est les adultes
discutent evene vous n'avez pas je vais
votre période d'essai je vous signal
mais si tu veux l'emmener à miami tu
peux non une équipe et ramène moi des
résultats si tu m'emmènes à miami
ciry-le-noble pendant cinq minutes ça
vaut une bise
non non c'est trop tôt mon équipier
failli vous êtes à ce gentil flic giflé
corps y ait la meilleure organisatrice
de mariage de tout atlanta qui fait se
cache-t-il away et tu crois que tu
m'impressionnes qui compte faire quoi
minus élever le débat
mais au frère de la loi des cendres sur
la ville d'ys là encore je tends colline
entre les deux vieux coq va sûrement
entreposer son matos dans le port je
vous conseille de me dire où il se
trouve a lâché mon nez le jeu serait
croyez-moi ça vous au nord de vouloir le
couvrir mais j'ai regardé lorsqu'on
téléphone est le premier nom que j'ai vu
c'est colette mais seppi 7 connais tu
sais quoi ça serait à wittes et les âges
il avait créé alors c'est clair
le meilleur était pour la faune qui sait
et j'ai écouté votre sonnerie c'est la
sonnerie du sinn ça coûte pas un sou que
dalle
depuis que vous êtes là j'ai eu une
fusillade dans une mouette une vingtaine
de plaintes contre vous et une fois que
you qui explose ça sauf qu'on n'y est
pour rien dans l'explosion le reste
c'est nous encore on fait qu' on se
protège toi et moi combien de la
compagnie
tu met le clignotant c'est un réflexe
qu'on n'a pas droit
jetez vos arbres encore c'est le stress
mes nerfs ont lâché c'est humain oh mon
dieu c'est un zombie dans la tête comme
de mme clinton